welcome back this is usually the part of
the show where we discuss studies that
make no sense
frankly we're mailing it in but instead
we're going to showcase alaska's most
famous comedian
alaska's
only comedian
give a big round of applause for our
friend jamie lisso
oh man
that's so true what greg just said i was
at the bar and this guy goes what's the
comedy scene like in alaska and i go
you're you're talking to it
this is the whole thing inside my shirt
uh
dude we i travel all over doing comedy
and it's fun to watch how different
states respond to the pandemic and i
just wanted to give some props i like
how in texas you guys went hey you know
this whole covet thing we're gonna we're
gonna
skip it
you guys did it
i was so excited to be i was like
nervous and excited so i got here super
early because i'm always worried about
where to park that's me right there it's
my truck um
try to tow it you'll kill people
it's staying right there uh
coveted really made comedy tough though
man it was weird even the shows we did
have were bizarre like i saw this one
performer the entire time he was on
stage he wore a mask
yeah it just kind of ruined it you know
he was a ventriloquist
[Applause]
or was he
[Applause]
it just feels free here though it feels
free i was in an uber and i go to this
guy it's just the vibe is different you
know i go so you guys aren't social
distancing and you're not like wearing
masks anymore and the guy goes no dude
we're not afraid you know and i believe
him because i was sitting on his lap
and um
yeah facing him like oh this guy doesn't
care man he's uh
this guy is into it
i'm gonna be totally honest i get
intimidated sometimes being in texas
because there's like a lot of real men
here you know
and um and i don't know if you can tell
by looking at me but i'm not exactly
like what you would call
i'm like a man's man
do you i'm not even really what what you
would call like a woman's man
i went to the doctor once i thought
something was wrong with me i go dude
could you like do some testing i feel
like i don't have a lot of like the guy
tendencies like i don't hunt or fight or
anything and the doctor goes yeah we
could do like a testosterone thing we
can figure it out for you so he comes
back like a half hour later he's got a
clipboard and he looks very serious and
he goes i'm glad you came in today man
because it turns out
you are what's known
as a huge
[Applause]
and i go come on dude there's no way
that's an actual diagnosis
and the guy goes okay you got me uh it's
not an actual diagnosis but i knew i
could call you that and you wouldn't do
anything
[Music]
based on the testing
[Applause]
oh man but it's good it's like we i have
so i'm a married guy i have um three
children and sometimes people will say
jamie do you have a favorite kid which
if there's parents out there you guys
know you're not supposed to you know i
have one
um
i'll just tell you it's my neighbor's
kid
you guys he's just adorable i got a
picture of him on my phone here
um
so i am divorced
and i but i don't feel like it has to be
a negative thing you know if you're out
there and you're in love i hope you stay
together forever and stay in love but i
do feel like i have to tell you uh for
anybody that's kind of like on on the
fence
um you get it feels pretty good over
here on this side
yeah i can't explain it here's a way to
know if you should get divorced if
people start telling you negative things
about divorce
and none of it sounds that bad
but they but these are negatives these
are the negative things
my friend goes dude you can't get
divorced man you're gonna have to move
out of your house and live alone in a
crabby apartment
i go dude when is the soonest we could
do something like that
i don't think the lady that lady likes
me that i live with
he goes yeah but dude you're only able
to see your kids on the weekends i go
that sounds amazing too to be honest
with you
oh my god i love these kids but i don't
want to take them to school it's a pain
in the ass
i want those i want those fun dad
weekends
you got any more bad news
people do not know how to react when you
tell me getting divorced i'm like very
happy my ex-wife is very happy she's a
cold chick my friends didn't know what
to say i was married for 16 years
and a year before that we met that's a
long time and my friend goes dude he
goes i'm excited for you because now
you're going to be able to go out there
into the world and get some strange
which does sound kind of exciting
because to tell you guys the god's
honest truth
i wasn't even getting any
familiar
that's the kind you're legally supposed
to get do you know what i mean but what
a wonderful crowd listen i'd love you to
check out i have a show on netflix with
rob schneider it's called real robin i'm
real proud of it and we tour together
and stuff and it's just sometimes i
don't want people to think like that
like all i do is ride off the success of
rob schneider um
it's a lot of what i do
but i also have stuff i do completely on
my own if you guys like my comedy you
want to check out things i do completely
separately please check out my website
it's a rob schneidersfriend.com you can
go on there and just check it out my
name is jamie nice to see you guys
[Applause]
awesome jamie lissau everyone he's a
funny guy hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else